more than 200 christmas eve flights
canceled nationwide united and delta
blamed a surge in covid cases especially
because of the omicron variant hector
mohia live this morning at reed
international airport hector this is not
the way that folks want to start their
holiday with these concerns
it's not and people are saying hey we
only get one christmas eve day out of
the entire year so just imagine how
upset they are having to spend some
extra hours or perhaps half a day at the
airport here at harry reid international
airport you can see just how quiet it is
down below at baggage claim and up at
the second floor if you're about to come
to the airport that's what you can
expect really no line at the checkpoint
for tsa for the d and sea gates and this
is all happening as the tsa says holiday
air travel
is rebounding to pre-pandemic numbers
with millions expected to travel for the
holiday weekend and here's what's
happening we're told by united airlines
well they had to chop more than a
hundred christmas eve flights at
airports all across the country and they
say it's because of the omicron variant
and they called it proactive planning
the nationwide spike in covet cases this
week had a direct impact on their flight
crews as well as their operations crews
delta airlines also came in with
cancellations cutting about almost 100
flights for today both airlines now
apologizing for the huge disruption is
having on a holiday christmas eve and
you know a lot of people celebrate
christmas today on christmas eve so if
you are coming down to the airport here
at harry reid your best bet is to get
dropped off the parking garages got full
yesterday that includes long-term
parking at terminal 1 and the economy
lot over at terminal three both of those
are closed reporting live hector mejia
live local now